Mario Lopez the guy who played AC Slater
on Saved by the Bell which you never
watched so I never watched it to shame
and honestly it's a good TV show is it
absent Mario Lopez says this very very
over over pedestrian yeah
caveat after caveat a very very mild I'm
not sure if three-year-olds should be
allowed to change their gender yeah
that's essentially what he says and then
is annihilated and a couple of days
later it comes back with the most
groveling apology comments I made were
ignorant and insensitive and they now
have a deeper understanding of how
hurtful they were I have been and always
will be an ardent supporter of the
lgbtq+ community and I'm going to use
this opportunity to better educate
myself moving forward I will be more
informed and thoughtful right well every
time someone does that it gives more
power to the Worker movement and it
gives it gives that sort of Twitter mob
the the upper hand because it mean they
know it works it's like a picture vane
to terrorists you know once you once you
do it they know it works and they'll do
it again and again and again we've seen
it all the time people are forced to
apologize for things they said years ago
things that probably weren't even that
offensive that's not offensive that's an
opinion so and if you really believed it
or we didn't right if you believed it
stand by it yeah you know I mean it's
short you can change your mind about
stuff in three days
unlikely that degree what you're
actually having is a lot of pressure
from you know I mean people can say to
him but maybe someone sat down so don't
think about this thing about this any
good change line that's possible right
even in that case I would advise not
apologizing with him because it just
feeds the beast you know I doubt we saw
this with Kevin Hart and the Oscars for
jokes he tweeted eight years ago ten
years ago something like that and they
were jokes doesn't matter if they're
offensive they were jokes I I don't care
so again I probably but a good for him
he didn't apology said I bored he said I
apologized at the time I'm not gonna
keep apologizing for this yeah you know
did you see the Liam Neeson thing about
in February time yeah he said that his
close family member
had been sexually assaulted I did like
black guy so he walked around his
hometown with a cosh yeah just going
into black neighborhoods hoping to find
someone that was associate yeah and like
whoa hang on a second what's this guy
supposed to say because I found although
it's obviously quite a dark story yeah I
found it very very interesting yeah oh
my gosh this is this is how would I feel
what would what would I do in that
situation how would I act in that
situation you thinking about Liam Neeson
this guy yeah believe voice walking
around the dark streets of Ireland with
this caution his hand and I'm like what
an amazing story yeah I can't believe he
said actually I can't believe he said
that to a journalist and didn't think
about the consequences of saying it but
there is something to be said for his
honesty it's but it's a horrible it's a
horrible idea that someone can be so
traumatized by something they behave in
such a vile way and by his own admission
it was a vile and you know it did his
own shock after himself yeah but does
that not like that sort of a thing
educates everybody yeah yeah that's sort
of a story cuz I'm like I've never heard
anything like that before yeah even in
fiction I've never heard anything like
that before and I think Wow
but what was your interest what was
weird about that is it I don't know why
the won't movement got so angry about
that because actually what he was making
was a really woke point because they
believed that white people are
essentially racist anyway and so this
was just sort bolstering their view so I
don't know why they weren't happy about
this to be honest but yeah they went for
him it's an unforgiving I mean this is
the thing about the whole the whole woke
things you can never if you make a
mistake once you were tired for life you
can never be forgiven because it is a
religion and they don't think redemption
is possible because those why than Mario
Lopez you've got this window of whatever
like maybe yeah seven days or something
like that within which you can recant
right and as long as you do your self
flagellation over whatever particular TV
station or your press release it is that
you do then maybe you get right but that
I mean and the point he was raising is
in a discussion we need to have right
the question about gender is a
discussion we absolutely need to have so
anyone who knows anything about gender
that has read sort of theories of gender
gender is not as the worker movement
claimed a social construct it is a very
very complicated combination of social
and biological factors right and the
problem is that there
faith-based position about gender has
been as been adopted particular in
Canada for instance by governments and
actually we need to have a much bigger
discussion before these sort of policies
are adopted we need to actually talk
about and decide whether they're right
or not it's not correct that that gender
is solely something to do with culture
largely
I mean certainly the the obvious example
is that you dress boys in blue and girls
in pink whereas in fact you know go back
hundred two hundred years it was the
reverse right so those things are
arbitrary feminism second white feminism
spent years trying to break down the
idea of of gender norms and gender
stereotyping right what's wrong with a
boy being effeminate with what why'd you
start questioning the same well that's
maybe he's a girl now maybe he's an
effeminate boy and that's okay what's
wrong with a girl being a tomboy being
butch well it's like what there's none
that do you remember tomboys yet because
Tom boys haven't been around as far as I
can remember for about ten years when in
fact the recent play of the was a teeny
blind claim was it Mallory towers even
and they cast a non-binary actor to play
the tomboy character okay it was an Emma
rice production know that this says this
says a lot that it's almost like the
concept of a butch girl is now something
we don't understand anymore no no no
it's a boy in a girl's body this is
deeply conservative right it's it's
hugely conservative I saw a documentary
at trans kids where the the parents were
talking about they're there because they
said that we've got this little girl now
and we're so happy because we don't have
to watch our little boy mincing about
like little I see like a little gay
alright so we fixed him we fixed about
Mike you know and without any sense of
self-awareness or but actually that
points to a very interesting thing about
the trans debate which we're not really
addressing is to what extent is this
actually just a rehabilitated homophobia
to what extent is this just us fixing
people into rigid ideas of what it means
to be a man and what it means to be a
woman I remember seeing a debate between
performative could David oil and Lauren
Harris who is a transgender woman was
formerly a man whose family male and
Lauren said where he during the
interview she said I always knew I was a
woman because I used to buy lots of
shoes right which
actually just is endorsing the most bass
grouse stereotype about women and
commercialism that you can imagine women
aren't all Imelda Marcos you know they
don't have that's not what it in
wardrobes yeah it doesn't mean you're a
woman just because you like to I used to
play with dolls as a kid I'm not a woman
yeah you know it doesn't matter and so
that's my big concern that's what I
would like to have that I'm not saying
that I know all the answers or that I
have a full understanding of the
situation what I am saying is I've read
a lot about it and I would like to have
a serious proper public discussion about
these issues without being shouted at
and called a transfer over and have
someone hit me with a bike and bike lock
enough have a milkshake on my face well
be being able to be under the age of 16
and not being allowed to have sex but
being allowed to change your sex right
it's not viously a problem because
having sex will last for probably first
time maybe about three minutes but like
changing your sexes the rusty life right
it's it's it's a really seriously you
know but I've composed no one
identifying this I have total sympathy
with someone who genuinely feels that
they are in the wrong body of quality um
yes
so so so so to suggest that to have
misgivings about any kind of chemical
interventional puberty inhibitor of
offer of a child is not the same thing
as being anti trans rights it should be
actually the two are completely
compatible we need to have a serious
discussion about that right but we're
not having that discussion we're just
throwing insults it's really sad
[Music]
you